well there's been a ton of focus on the
Democratic presidential primary and
rightly so there have been some really
bad new polls for incumbent Republican
senators that I want to tell you about
today one involves our favorite
perpetually disappointed Republican
senator from Maine Susan Collins who
despite her concern and her
disappointment over Donald Trump's
actions ultimately always falls in line
and supports him whether it's voting
against impeaching Trump convicting
Trump on impeachment whether it's
ultimately voting for Brett Kavanaugh
well Susan Collins is now down four
points in a new poll against her
Democratic challenger Sarah Gideon
admittedly that's a democratic leaning
poll but she's also down to Sarah Gideon
in a recent Colby College poll it would
be a major accomplishment if we were
able to remove Susan Collins she's been
in the Senate she won in 1996 sworn in
in January of 97 she won her
re-elections pretty easily in 2002 in
2008 in 2014 in recent polls her Sarah
Gideon is up by one in a kolbe poll
Colby College Bowl 43 to 42 a lot of
undecided there and then in a more
recent PPP poll an admittedly dem lead
II leaning poll Gideon is up by 447 to
43 then we go to Arizona in Arizona
we've got incumbent Republican senator
martha mcsalley facing a challenge from
astronaut Mark Kelly who's twin brother
Scott Kelly has been a guest on this
program and they're once again in a
predictive insights poll Kelly was up 3
in December that's an old poll by now
and then a few days ago in a PPP poll
Mark Kelly up 547 to 42 still many
undecided is there as well but this is
not good news for the Republican
candidates there are just two these are
just two of the Senate races we're
looking at where Republicans could be
replaced by Democratic challengers so
the message here is while we pay
attention to and work on the Democratic
primary and eventually the fight to
remove Donald Trump in November
we shouldn't forget about the fact that
it's possible possible but it's an
uphill battle but it's possible to take
the Senate from Republicans in 2020 and
even if it's unlikely any seat we can
win in 2020 is the seat that doesn't
need to be made up in 2022 when
hopefully Democrats will be able to take
control of the Senate we don't know how
you know Biden versus Bernie as nominees
will affect the down ballot the House
and Senate races we can't control how a
good or bad economy in November could
help or hurt down ballot races but when
we have these numbers this tells us we
have to be working on these races and
now a lot of people will rightly point
out are these really progressive
Democrats in these races they'll say you
know Mark Kelly hasn't said a word about
single-payer Sarah Gideon wants to
expand Medicaid and add a public option
it's basically the Biden position on
health care that's completely true and
yet these folks would be orders of
magnitude better than the Republicans
that are currently in place period and
we don't want to miss the forest for the
trees on these these Senate races that's
my view now tell me if you disagree and
at this point if you try to push someone
else into the Democratic race to get a
real progressive in there I believe it's
guaranteed the Republicans get reelected
I think these are the candidates in
these races to remove Republicans if you
disagree I want to hear from you I just
don't see it I just don't see how you
make that work at this point in time